so picture this your band not just from
streaming on Twitch or competing in the
eSport you love your band from playing
any game that a developer publishes now
we've seen some pretty crazy fans in the
past right Tyler one phase Jarvis
ibuypower
but this situation is so insane because
that developer
well it's EA
[Music]
before we get into it I just want you
guys to know that if you want to see
more content like this it really helps
us if you would like the video subscribe
to the channel because well then we know
that you want more of it and we can give
it to you now back to lifetime bans so
if you didn't know EA's FIFA series is
really really really popular from a
general gaming perspective and while its
eSports scene is small potatoes when
compared to League of Legends or csgo it
does have a dedicated community a World
Championship and a three million dollar
prize pool for the 2020 season have
waited for a while champion to step up
and one of the scenes most infamous
competitors is this dude
Kurt fennec and to say that Kurt and EA
don't get along well that would be a
gigantic understatement for years he's
been openly critical but the way EA has
been handling the FIFA series okay I was
writing essays on their stupid-ass beta
forums explaining the issues that he's
gonna cause and I told them to remove
the combat one strikers dribble what
dribblin this feud between EA Kurt truly
started popping off in November of 2019
when they banned him from competing in
any EA sponsored tournament after he
allegedly threatened other players and
employees and we'll get to that
situation in just a minute and now after
years of this ongoing feud EA what
nuclear and on February 24th completely
banned Kurt from accessing any EA
service or playing any EA published
video game so what the hell happened
here
like I said Kurt's been really vocal
about EA for a while now it's honestly
become a part of his brand from his
perspective the game's extremely buggy
the AI is completely unrealistic and EA
doesn't seem to be listening to any
community feedback really his main point
is that FIFA is not truly ready for
eSports competitive FIFA FIFA eSports
whatever the hell you want to call it
officially
yes the games were trash yes the game
was not suited to be any eSports 100%
and it's not just him parts of the FIFA
community online are also pretty vocal
about the way they think EA has been
mishandling the franchise it's just that
well Kurt is a little more vocal than
everyone else this isn't the first time
that EA is decided Kurt's criticisms
crossed the line back in October of 2018
they hit him with a two-month
competitive band for allegedly launching
personal attacks against other players
he served at his band and while he
continued to [ __ ] on FIFA in the EA
things died down for a while okay so
fast-forward to February of 2019 where
Kurt interrupted a post match interview
by the Royal not being able to okay
maybe right maybe they are why don't you
okay you go cut you go concentrate on
your game and we'll all be able to watch
you this blew up within the community
and Kurt made a video about it talking
about the fact that EA didn't want to
stream his games or give him a mic after
he won finally
I show my game on stream and I made
their Bokan game too good
Kate finishes no every single game that
was on stream and the guy that was he
was getting their mic they wouldn't give
me a mic might let me speak to my god
time paper
why let me speak to the paper they
wouldn't get me now from EAS perspective
you can understand why they wouldn't
want to give this dude a microphone now
here's where things get crazy after
finishing a match Kurt pops off on his
opponent talks trash about EA and then
he spits on an EA branded scarf you
don't baby even on this piece of trash
game [ __ ] you he ain't white I'm not
playing this guy [ __ ] you call me all of
you
Abbeville widened the logo and it's this
video that seemed to trigger EA banning
him from competing in any tournament
sponsored by the publisher in their
statement what EA is basically saying is
that they gave him multiple chances in
the fact that he keeps talking trash and
being vulgar on stream and during
matches well that's why they decided to
ban him from competing
now obviously Kurt was pissed about this
he posted his own statement to Twitter
and followed that up with a video
defending his actions okay so at this
point the story this is Kurt's second
ban and yet there's another one coming
soon then after news hit of this ban a
bunch of EA employees who work on FIFA
including some Community Managers had
their personal Twitter accounts half and
those hacked accounts were even tweeting
things out in support of Kurt that was
November fast forward to last week where
Kurt got hit with a third band after a
now-deleted YouTube video where he calls
out Community Managers and EA employees
by name without bathing around the bush
to moshed a specific reason as I made
the video about a week and a half ago
something like that which was about the
EA Community Managers where I
specifically said about a about an en
community manager directly amongst other
things I said I called him a bomb
incompetent waste of sperm those same
people that he calls out in his video
were the ones that had their personal
Twitter accounts hacked okay so Monday
February 24th EA posts this statement to
Twitter announcing that Kurt is
permanently banned the FIFA account he's
had for over a decade it's gone and the
important part of the statement reads as
follows Kurt has continued to post
abusive and threatening messages and
videos about EA employees and
competitive players on social media and
he has encouraged others to do the same
we will not tolerate threatening
behavior as a result today Kurt's EA
account will be banned from playing our
games and accessing our services due to
these serious and repeated violations
and so based on the language that EA is
using it seems that Kirk can't play any
games that EA is associated with and so
in one statement EA is effectively ended
this guy's entire career I'm not to
English mass whole career and look it's
not hard to understand both perspectives
here so Kurt is saying that he hasn't
done anything wrong
he hasn't broken any of EA's rules or
their tos and again this is a gigantic
issue for him
EA and FIFA was his entire career from
EAS perspective somebody's consistently
talking trash about your game and
allegedly harassing your employees it's
a problem and honestly there is a line
probably in there TOS somewhere about
the fact that you can't spit on their
merch and in their eyes it's their ball
so they can take it away if they want to
okay so that was in November now
fast-forward to February of this year
like last week and then I was in jump
cut today was IA little too
[Music]